amazon is launching a new effort to
crack down on counterfeit goods sold on
the site and a company executives giving
the first on-camera interview about this
program the online retail giant has more
than 300 million active users they spent
more than 141 billion dollars with ABI
on products last year now most of the
goods sold on the platform come from
third-party vendors with Amazon helping
facilitate the sale but Amazon has now
come under fire for not doing enough to
vet those third-party sellers some are
accused of copying patented products and
potentially putting customers in danger
Carter Evans has his story you'll see it
only on CBS this morning would you feel
so helpless
Dennis Jacobsen knew something was wrong
when her service dog Riley became
severely ill after taking the pet
supplements she regularly orders from
Amazon then she got an email from the
retail giant saying the products from a
third-party seller may not be the real
thing as you can see this is chalky and
brown and this is a white fine fine
powder the company that makes the
supplement nutramax says the counterfeit
versions of its product sold on Amazon
were a threat to pet safety and
well-being we've continued to make
progress in reducing the amount of
counterfeit our store but the fact is
that today that number is not zero there
still are counterfeit door mesh meta is
Amazon's vice president of customer
trust and partner support he says the
company caught three billion suspicious
listings last year before buyers even
saw them but can't say how many
counterfeits actually made it onto the
site are you able to say how many
counterfeits you discovered over a year
period I don't think I have that data
point Amazon has been sued many times
over this by people who claim that
Amazon is responsible for facilitating
the sale of the counterfeit product
where does the responsibility lie our
focus first and foremost is how do we
prevent counterfeit from ever getting in
our store but when you do find one whose
fault is it and so if there is one we'll
make sure the customer is made whole on
that product and we're gonna work with
the customer or work with brands to go
after that bad actor on average 95
percent of the time we investigate that
and take action within eight hours
inventor mark Lowe pre ATO says that
wasn't the case
for his business the forearm forklift
lifting straps make your forearms a
fulcrum after listing his forearm
forklift on Amazon he says he found
dozens of fakes some using the same name
logo and photos this is my wife this is
me lo pre Otto says it's not only
extremely difficult to track down the
bad actors but also to take any legal
recourse against them we have to find
them deep in their website then report
them still more and more days are
passing and then finally they may or may
not take down the listing amazon filed
suit against a few sellers who were
counterfeiting low Prieto's product and
160 thousand dollars in may 2000 18 that
money went to low pre auto we really
want to go as fast as we can but now
meta says amazon wants to make it easier
to remove fakes by teaming up with
sellers in a new program called project
zero this is the first time we've given
brands the ability to directly remove
stuff from our store let's pretend
you're a brand who's in project zero he
showed us how approved sellers can now
identify and delete suspected
counterfeit listings with just a few
clicks you're given them a lot of
responsibility we are giving brands a
lot of responsibility we will always
have some level of vetting there's some
powerful tools in there and you wouldn't
want some random person showing up and
starting to remove products from our
store the company says part of that
vetting process is keeping the program
by invite only 500 brands are currently
participating but meta says that number
will grow significantly Amazon is also
using artificial intelligence to search
for fakes and offering sellers an option
to add a special code to each product
that buyers can scan with Amazon's app
to make sure it's real Bob Barr kc with
the international anti counterfeiting
coalition says consumers need to be
aware of what he calls the three P's
price point of sale and packaging if
it's too good to be true
it's probably fake packaging
misspellings specifically for Amazon you
also may want to look at the customer
reviews that it was a verified purchaser
you really think that's gonna make the
difference here I don't think that will
make the difference on its own
so when I look at project zero it really
is the combination of all the automation
all the machine learning and everything
we can do up front the success the
growth of Amazon is all built on having
to have customers trust us small medium
businesses and brands trust us because
that's the only way we're gonna thrive
for CBS this morning Carter Evans
Seattle I'm glad they're addressing it
you know as someone who orders a lot of
stuff from Amazon I don't want fake
products that could be dangerous and
also you when you hear them talk about
it it sounds vague and then when you see
they've given product makers the power
to delete others that's pretty that's a
lot of power again we'll see if that
works out we're paying attention